happy turkey day yes right out of the
gate what what's going on we're playing
boyle bingo thanksgiving edition
everyone filled out their cards with
possible charles related scenarios first
bingo gets 100 bucks i had boil calls at
turkey day in the center square
boyle explains that they lobsters at the
first thanksgiving they did back in that
time they called lobster's ocean bugs
and i'll just mark it off for you i
think i got the winning card here boyle
tells us that he played pocahontas in
his third grade play all the girls were
too big
this is a fun one boyle says gobble
gobble gobble well now that i know you
want me to say that i'll just say it
with two gobbles
gobble god it just it just sounds right
that way
i don't like this game
boyle objects to boyle bingo come on
guys boyle says come on guys that's two
for terry well guess what i can spoil
your little game by sitting over here
quietly all day and doing nothing
anybody have boiled falls on the floor
no one that's a victory that's a victory
for boyle
boom
boys
oh no what happened don't worry about it
i'm fine yeah geez amy back off leave
the guy alone all right huddle up
everybody bring it in so he wouldn't say
what happened which can only mean one
thing he's in a fight club no he did it
doing something he's embarrassed by like
smiling only question is how do you hurt
your arm smiling could be a sports
injury i sprained my wrist in college
playing field hockey men's field hockey
yeah it's much more violent than the
women's game we're not allowed to wear
anything that protects our breasts
attention everyone i can hear you
speculating about the nature and origin
of my injury from my office i tripped
over an uneven sidewalk i did not think
it was relevant to your jobs the jobs
which you should all be doing right now
get to work
do you want to know how i actually hurt
my wrist
yes i was hula hooping
kevin and i attended class for fitness
and for fun oh my god i've mastered all
the moves
the pizza toss
the tornado the scorpion the
oopsie doodle
why are you telling me this
because no one
will ever believe you
no no
you sick son of a [ __ ] amy santiago is
a few minutes late and we're all trying
to guess why i like to play
i'd say she's in line at the bank
this is fun it is fun but you're all
wrong she clearly slipped through a
subway grade and is having terrible sex
with a mole man
there she is amy where have you been
we've been worried sick do you care to
explain yourself i'm just 70 seconds
late it's not a big deal don't worry
about it santiago you will tell us and
you will tell us now
there's a problem at the bank
hot damn so i've been planning how to
zing madeline when she puts the metal on
i have the perfect line lunch time is
over
so it's a play on lunch time yes
devastating burn sir but you know what
would really show her is if you said
nothing at all oh interesting
interesting
let madeline know she's not even worth
my staying up all night crafting zingers
lunch time took you all night trust me
turn the other cheek
which i recently learned is about faces
and not butts but works either way
yes
i should be the bigger person i
shouldn't be hard given that madeline's
not technically
a person
for meritorious service the nypd bestows
this award on detectives rosa diaz jake
peralta and captain
raymond holt
raymond
madeline you won
go ahead and go out you toad
thank you for this honor
deputy
chief oh
okay
you're welcome
lunch time is over boom did it
had it both ways no regrets
falcon one do we have a go
the light is green tiger one what are
you gonna say when he crashed through
the window hey there sorry for dropping
in goosebumps jake
goosebumps is the equipment secure check
weapon loaded check did you have
breakfast what that's not on the
checklist i added it because i care
about you no i did not have breakfast
unacceptable look in your pocket
hey there's little chocolate chips in
this yeah i'm not an idiot i know how to
trick my best friend into eating his
fiber all right
bar digested mission go
hey there
sorry for dropping in
was it cool it felt really cool yeah
yeah it's pretty cool pretty cool well
we're wrong hi you have fudge on cheek
oh from the breakfast bar boyle guys
guys guys
scully has a mason jar full of lemonade
you called us in here to tell us that no
i called you in here to change your
lives for you see a mere five minutes
ago hitchcock introduced me to his new
goldfish who lives in
an identical mason jar oh this isn't
gonna end well there are two possible
outcomes and we're gonna bet on which
one happens first so will hitchcock put
fish food and scully's lemonade or will
skully drink hitchcock's goldfish now
you would think that putting fish food
into lemonade hitchcock just drank his
own fish what no
it's not a secret meeting jake
it's an intervention the tips have to go
what
why jake we're worried about you and you
look very stupid come on guys i think
they're kind of cool retro no they're
terrible amy come on you're digging the
tips right no i feel like i'm kissing
vanilla ice there was a time you would
have jumped at that chance they have to
go
all right you guys got me
i did it as a joke i kept them
ironically pretty funny right
i'm just gonna head out
i'll admit it i went too deep down there
in florida
at one point i think
i forgot where the tip of me ended and
the base of the tips began before we
just chop them off would anybody like to
say
some final words no that was one word
that counts thank you rosa okay i'm
ready
sorry i'm late everyone but trust me
it's worth it me and jake are tip buds
you know what i do see it it's bad it
looks bad ladies and gentlemen we are
gathered here today to answer an age-old
question right what's amy's deal is she
single no we're dating come on the
question is who here does the best
impression of captain raymond holt
you'll be judged on voice body language
and overall lack of flair everyone will
perform the same scenario captain holt
eating a marshmallow for the very first
time let the halt off begin
what is this glutinous monstrosity
before me the sugar in this is quite
sweet
that's your hold impression i can hear
him doing that looks like a sticky
pillow i don't care for it classical
music
what's going on here what are you doing
captain hey nothing just
eating some marshmallows care for one
marshmallow
i knew it
hey there boyle how was your weekend
well actually i got a little sick oh
really i'm sorry to hear that man yeah
bullets over broadway was on tv
i came down with a big old diane weast
infection
so do you recognize any of these men i
was hiding in the bathroom stall so i
didn't see his face but
i heard him he was singing along to the
music at the bar do you remember what he
was singing i think it was that song i
want it that way backstreet boys i'm
familiar okay
number one could you please sing the
opening to i want it that way really
okay
you are
my fire
number two keep it going the one
desire
number three believe
when i
say number four i
wanted that
i never wanna
[Applause]
oh chills literal chills it was number
five number five killed my brother oh my
god i forgot about that part i am loving
this machine that charles brought in it
is nice the trick is to let the coffee
warm up the room temperature i'm already
on my second cup this is my third
stop
you're drinking too much
whoa what's going on charles why are you
talking so slow i'm not i'm normal
[Music]
oh my god if you're not going so that
means we're going faster are we going
fast can i tell if we're going fast
we're going fast at all in any way
whatsoever i feel like we're going slow
and everywhere whatsoever kept not even
great excellent amazing i feel better
than i've ever found in a moment in my
entire life so we're all fine yep
you